[Music]
This
Umm, old man, you're
slipping, so call me with the number 3.
[Music] I'm
slipping, but how long will this white be
until there are no more stones? I'm
sorry, I can't move anymore. That's how you spell it.
Can you lend me your horse?  That's the story.
Bring your worries to me.
[Music]
When you're done chopping wood, go fetch water. Hurry up. [
Music] I can't help but
stare at your feet. You're doing this. You don't have
time.
Or rather, that old man lives alone in this house.
Well, I guess it's because I'm
meeting him for the first time. I
wonder if he's
just making me work like he won't really lend me his money.
Even if it were us, it would be natural.
We're slaves, after
all.  You're a slave. I don't
know what's going on with you. This is a contract. I'll
lend you a horse, and in exchange, you'll do chores around my house.
When you borrow the horse, and
when you return it, you
understand.
[Music]